文部将がバカだから体育を否定するんやね
だから教育学を学んだ人はダメない愛の
定義ができずに間だあだ本当にマスコミは
馬鹿やからね例えば自分の子供を殺し
ちゃう母親がおると本能の定義は系統発生
進化やねこうやって
[音楽]
あの先生の教育論で本能を鍛えることに
よって歩流すていうのが本のの力に書いて
あったと思うんですけどそこに至った家庭
について伺いたいですああれはねちょっと
考えてみたら分かる
じゃん人間ができた時にはまだ理性なんで
ないじゃないそうよね言葉も喋らんやった
んやからそれがだんだん理性ができてきた
理性ができることを進歩したというその辺
のとこは分かるんねということは理性が
なかった時にどうやって理性を作った本の
ね本のの中にそれが組み込まれとった特に
仏教のあれ読むと分かる因果
合法原因があるから結果が出るぞと本能の
中に理性を作るような要素があるもんねで
理性ができた具体的には合法だ合というの
は行動のこと行動によって技術ができる法
というのは無いという自覚やなよく因が
王法っというけど方法の方がいえわ具体的
な行動によって具体的な理性ができる正
前説だから本能が正しいということは本能
による行動も正しい正しい行動をすると
正しい理性ができるそういうことが人間は
できたんやないかそれがどこで正しい行動
ができたか意思なんよ本は正しいから本能
による意思は正しい意思が非常に細かい
行動の説をやってくれる目的に合わした
調節をしてくれるだから理性を消して本能
による行動をすれば正しい理性が
出来上がるその正しい理性のことを技術と
いうその正しい技術理性その作り方を学ぶ
のが体育だ体育というのはそういうもんや
ところが今学校でやってるのはスポーツだ
スポーツで出来上がった理性技術はその
スポーツにしか役に立たんやろそういう
ことになるだから体育で出来上がった技術
これは全ての進歩に役に立つだから学校は
体育をやらないかんねで今体育の意味が
分からんようになっちまったるもん
スポーツばっかりやっとるやないかそれも
進歩を抑えるようなやり方やろしいてはか
の汗かかしてはいかん熱中症があるから何
度以上の時はあれするな
とこれはもううまい人にはできんだけどね
こいつをあれするとま今乗っちまったけど
これ最初乗らんやろこうやってあのもう
技術ができ
ちまっパーンと跳ね返るじゃん乗せようと
すると失敗する乗せようとするのが理性だ
からところがそれを捨てるんよでここに
集中するの持ったここにでね乗せようと
せんのやこの玉の下にここ皿を持って
いこうとするんともかくここに集中しとく
ことやそうすとねあのうまく乗るんよと
いうことは剣玉の練習をする時に集中力を
養うつもりで練習をするそうすると他の
ことにも使えるんだどんなことにでもこれ
が体育的なやり方でこれただ繰り返して
ともかくうまくなろうとして繰り返すやろ
普通これがスポーツねだから体育でやっ
とけばこれ閉めたもんやどんなことでも
できるように
なる文部将がバカだから体育を否定するん
やね彼らが体育を否定する理由は奴らが
グズやからああいう役人っていうのは
みんな体育嫌いやろ揃いも揃って嫌いよね
行動が嫌いやけどね行動しなければわから
ない何にも行動した上で自分がそれを身に
つけてそれが理解っていうんやだから教育
学を学んだ人はダメない長年先生をやって
で初めて教え方が身につくわけやろ理性と
本能の定義っていうか違いはどういうこと
なん
ですまず
本能からやね本能の定義は系統発生進化や
ね系統発生的に獲得した行動のプログラム
これは精神そのものの定義になるわけねだ
から理性はその本能者なしに理性を自分で
作るわけやから自分で作り上げた行動の
プログラムこれが理性な理性は自分で作る
もんだ本能はあるもんだただし本能論から
行くとね自分に対する本能体温を36と5
分に保つとか風邪引いたら熱を出すとか
体温が高くなったら汗を出すとかそういう
本能は何にもせんでもちゃんとある自分が
維持できること維持のための本能やなだ
けども他人に対する本能というのはその
経験がないと出てこないでこれでねと
恐ろしいのは本能だから当然だと思うのに
それに反することが起きてくるんよ例えば
自分の子供を殺しちゃう母親がおるじゃん
あんなもんあるわけないよねそそんなもん
があったら人間滅びちゃうからさとろがで
こういう動物実験があるネズミが子供をむ
ま8匹とか10匹子供産その母ネズミのね
乳首をね全部メスで切り取っちまうそこ
ネズミがおっぱい末やろその状態を作ると
母ネズミに血管が出てくるの自分の子供が
よそのネズミに襲われて食われとっても
知らん顔した守ろうとしないつまり母性愛
がないの母性愛っていうのは自分の乳首を
座れることによってその吸った子供を
守ろうとする本問これがもうせ愛の定義が
できずに愛だ愛だて本当にマスコミはバカ
やからねアコス全てなんて騒ぎ出せや
JA